hey guys dr. Burke here in this video I
want to share my opinion on do we need
carbohydrates okay so now there's going
to be a lot of different viewpoints that
people are going to talk about I'm just
going to give my two cents I don't want
to get in an argument with anyone but
let me just give you some basics on what
I think is very workable but whatever
works for you go ahead and go for it so
people think they need carbohydrates
mainly for energy but you can run your
body on other types of calories you can
run your body on protein you can run
your body on fat and so you don't always
have to run your body on carbohydrates
so there's a Smith that you have like
all the energy you have in your body
comes from a carbohydrate not
necessarily true so let me just kind of
explain so you've got simple
carbohydrates and complex carbohydrates
simple carbohydrates are like sugar
honey agave nectar so what happens is
that goes in your body really fast and
it spikes the sugar it might give you
some temporary energy but then you're
going to come down because you have the
hormone called insulin that regulates
that but then complex carbohydrates have
a lot of additional things like fiber
that slow the breakdown and the
carbohydrate in the body and so it
doesn't create that same effect as table
sugar so here's the thing though let's
just kind of break down each type of
carbohydrate now some of this actually
contract contains proteins amino acids
but mainly it's a carbohydrate okay we
definitely need more vegetables not
initially for the carbohydrate but
mainly for the vitamins okay and the
minerals that's really why we need those
because that's where most of the
vitamins and minerals come from
it also has fiber but what fiber does
it's not necessarily something like a
bulking agent it's mainly to feed the
microbes your intestinal flora your good
bacteria live on microbes and they need
fiber and you don't have to get your
fiber from brand or grains you can get
it from the vegetable family okay
so that's why we need vegetables in
large quantities to beans now the thing
about beans is it doesn't turn into
as fast as other types of carbohydrates
however if you have a slow metabolism if
you're trying to lose weight I have
found that people have a hard time doing
this on beans because it's it's a lot of
carbs okay so if it works for you try it
if you have a slow metabolism you might
not want to consume very many beans okay
a lot of people have gas with beans as
well so that's my viewpoint on that no
fruits fruits are great but the problem
is that it can range from a high
glycemic index to a low glycemic index
if you have like berries and things
that's a little lower than apples apples
have like 19 to 30 grams of sugar per
Apple that's like a lot of sugar so the
thing about fruits is this on some
people it's going to slow them down to
lose weight okay they're not going to be
able to weight as fast now you're going
to have exceptions to the rule with
people with a faster metabolism but I'm
dealing with mainly women in their 50s
who having a hard time and I get the
fruit out of the diet and boom
everything starts going down a lot
easier so again you're going to have
exceptions but typically fruit it's just
too sweet it's too much carbohydrate now
there are viewpoints out there that you
see people that do a fruit diet and they
lose all this weight well probably
because they cut out all of the sugar
okay that's in the diet as well and
their metabolism might be a little bit
faster but I'm just talking about if you
take someone that's been dieting for
many years and you keep them on fruit
it's going to slow them down
I used to recommend fruit I don't
recommend fruit if you're trying to lose
weight okay there is some vitamins and
fruit maybe a little bit of berry but
not much okay now grains grains you have
like whole wheat bread and white bread
the whole thing here's the thing it's
very very similar sore glycemic index so
it does turn into sugar fairly fast and
I don't recommend grains for two reasons
number one there is not a lot of
nutrition in grains some people disagree
but just look it up it's not that high
if you compare to vegetables the other
thing is it's real hard in the digestive
system because it has glue
ten gluten is the protein in grains and
gluten creates all sorts of silly AK
problems in irritable bowel syndrome and
irritation to the colon and it's one of
those things that you just have to try
it yourself and see if it if you feel
better not consuming it okay I found
that when you consume grains you people
go out of bloating and you just have to
know yourself and just try it out the
other thing is starches so there are
diet alte that recommend tons of
starches and some people lose weight
some people don't well here's the point
I don't want to get into a whole debate
on starches I just want you to go ahead
and try it for yourself
eat starches for a week and see if you
lose weight and if you do great on my
experience is that you probably are not
going to lose weight because these
starches turn in sugar pretty down fast
it's not the highest sources of vitamins
compared to vegetables so I like to stay
away from these right here okay now if
you're trying to gain weight I think
potatoes are the best food that you can
consume okay
maybe wild rice if you're a high level
athlete doing marathons okay then you
might you have a high metabolism maybe
you're going to need some brown rice
maybe a potato but for the average
person their kid they can't get away
with it okay in summary do we need
carbohydrates well we do need
carbohydrates for our vitamins and
minerals and fiber okay hope you learned
something make some comments below and I
will see you in the next video